we'll now move from the world of
first-order differential equations to
the world of second-order differential
equations so what does that mean that
means that we're it's now going to start
involving the second derivative and the
first class that I'm going to show you
and this is probably the most useful
class when you're studying classical
physics are linear second order
differential equations so what is a
linear second order differential
equation so I think I touched on it a
little bit in the in our very first
intro video but it's something that
looks like this if I have a of X so some
function only of x times the second
derivative of Y with respect to X plus B
of x times the first derivative of Y
with respect to X plus C of X times y is
equal to some function just of that's
only a function of X so just to review
our terminology why is the second order
because the highest derivative here is
the second derivative so that makes it
second order and what makes it linear
well all of the coefficients on and I
want to be careful with the term
coefficients because traditionally we
view coefficients as always being
constants but here we have con we have
we have functions of X as coefficients
so in order for this to be a linear
differential equation a of X B of X C of
X and D of X they all have to be
functions only of X as I've drawn it
here and now before I we start trying to
solve this generally we'll we'll do a
special case of this where ABC are
constants and D is 0 so what will that
what look like so I can just rewrite
that is a so that now a is not a
function anymore it's just a number a
times the second derivative of Y with
respect to X plus B times the first
derivative plus C times y and instead of
having just a fourth constant as instead
of d of X I'm just going to set that
equal to Z
and by setting this equal to zero I have
now introduced you to the other form of
homogeneous differential equation and
this one is called homogeneous and it's
and I haven't made the connection yet on
how these second order differential
equations are related to the first-order
ones that I just introduced these other
homogeneous differential equations I
introduced you to I think they just
happen to have the same name even though
they're not that related so the reason
why this one is called homogeneous is
because you have it equal to zero so
this is what makes it homogeneous and
actually I do see more of a connection
between this type of equation and milk
where all the fat is spread out because
if you think about it no matter the
solution for all homogeneous equations
or when you kind of apply when you kind
of solve the equation they always equal
zero so they're they're homogenized I
guess it's the best way that I I can
draw any kind of parallel so we could
call this a second order right second
order linear right because a B and C
definitely are functions just of well
they're not even functions of X or Y
they're just constants so second order
linear homogeneous because they equals
zero differential equations and I think
you'll see that these are in some ways
are the most fun differential equations
to solve and actually often the most
useful because a lot of the applications
in classical mechanics this is all you
need to solve but they're the most fun
to solve because they all boil down to
algebra two problems and I'll touch on
that in a second but let's just think
about this a little bit think about what
the properties of these solutions might
be let me just throw out something let's
say that I don't know let's say that G
let's say that G of X is a solution G of
X is a solution so that means that a
times G prime prime plus B times G prime
plus C times G is equal to zero
right that these mean the same thing now
my question to you is what if I have
some constant times G is that still a
solution
so let's say so my question is is let's
say some constant C one G X C one times
G is this a solution well let's try it
out let's substitute this into our
original equation so a times the second
derivative of this would just be and
I'll switch colors here I'll switch
maybe let me switch to brown so a times
the second derivative of this would be
the constant every time you take a
derivative the constant just carries
over right so that'll just be a times C
one G prime prime plus the same thing
for the first derivative B times C one G
prime plus C times and this C is
different than the C one C times G and
let's see whether this is equal to zero
so we could factor out that C one
constant and we get C one times a G
prime prime plus B G prime plus C G and
lo and behold we already know because we
know that G of X is a solution we know
that this is true so this is going to be
equal to zero right because G is a
solution so if this is 0 C 1 times 0 is
going to be equal to 0 so this
expression up here is also equal to 0 or
another way to view it is that if G is a
solution to this second-order linear
homogeneous differential equation then
some constant times G is also a solution
so this is also a solution to the
differential equation and then the next
property I want to show you and this is
all going someplace don't worry
the next question I want to ask you if
okay we know that G of X is a solution
to the differential equation what if I
would also tell you that H of X H of X
is also a solution also a solution so my
question to you is is
G of X + H of X a solution if you add
these two two functions that are both
solutions if you add them together is
that still a solution of our original
differential equation
well let's substitute this whole thing
into our original differential equation
right so we'll have a times the second
derivative of this thing
well that's straighten straightforward
enough that's just G prime prime plus h
prime prime plus B times the first
derivative of this thing G prime plus h
prime plus C times this function G Plus
H and now what can we do let's
distribute all of these constants we get
a times G prime prime plus a times H
prime prime plus B times the first
derivative of G plus B times the first
derivative of H plus C times G plus C
times H and now we can rearrange them we
get a let's take this one let's take all
the G terms a times the second
derivative of G plus B times the first
derivative plus C times G that's these
three terms plus a times the second
derivative of H plus B times first
derivative plus C times H and now we
know that both G and H are solutions of
the original differential equation so by
definition well yeah by definition if
this is if G is a solution of the
original differential equation and this
was the left-hand side of that
differential equation this is going to
be equal to zero this is going to be
equal to zero and so is this going to be
equal to zero so we've shown that this
whole expression is equal to zero so if
you if G is a solution of the
differential equation of this
second-order linear homogeneous
differential equation and H is also a
solution then if you were to add them
together there ought that that the sum
of them is also solution
so in general if we show that G is a
solution and H is a solution you can add
them and we showed before that any
constant times them is also solution so
you could also say that some constant
times G of X plus some constant times H
of X is also a solution and you know
maybe that the constant in one of the
cases is 0 or something I don't know but
anyway these are useful properties for -
maybe internalize for second order
homogeneous linear differential
equations and in the next video we're
actually going to apply these properties
to figure out the solutions for these
and you'll see that they're they're
actually straightforward I would say a
lot easier than what we did when the the
previous first-order homogeneous
differential equations or the exact
equations this is much much easier I'll
see you in the next video